[Music]
what is up thick fam this is a breaking
breaking episode of the shop show cause
the year is coming to an end but you
know what we can't end this year we
can't go out like that that's not what
we do here at thick boy Studios we have
to do our first ever we've only been up
we've been open thick boy's been open
right under a year be a year around
January 8th all right so this is the
first ever annual thick boy Awards the
MMA Awards other people have their award
shows but it ain't thick boy Awards so
we're gonna give it to you in this
episode of The Shop show for the first
annual thick boy Awards is brought to
you by on it on it supplements the best
supplements on the planet the best
nootropic on the planet we're talking
about Alpha Brain I like the black label
Alpha Brain I like my stuff full sand
that's right I like the super intense
Alpha Brain the best nootropic on the
planet you want to save 10 off the best
supplements on the planet who can trust
the best workout gear the best nootropic
and also they're so confident in
alphabet if you don't like it you get
your money back don't even send the
Alpha Brain back eat your money back no
questions asked but you're gonna love it
go to audit.com job save temps off the
entire site all right the entire site
temps it off workout gear nootropics
Alpha Brain protein bars Warrior bars
workout gear everything
battle ropes on it.com shop 10 off now
let's get this bad boy started it is the
first ever annual thick boy Awards this
was voted on by the staff here at thick
boy Studios so a lot went into this and
each winner is gonna get not a belt this
isn't fire the kid guess the year you're
gonna get one of those
nasty fancy gold chains with the thick
boy emblem on it it'll be delivered to
you guys so keep
on the lookout for it people are
stealing mail these days so make sure
you get if you get stolen we're not on
it and I can refund it that's on you
right so hopefully you get it you can
wear it and post it all right but that's
what each winner is going to get so
let's kick this off
now you got to start off with the
knockout of the Year 2022 had some
insane insane fights
but only one knockout sticks in this old
CT brain that comes from our boy Michael
Chandler now we're just not talking
about a regular knockout we're talking
about knocking out one of the greatest
light weights on the planet one of the
best most Savage 155s on the planet the
man who at one point in his career might
have been the best 155 on the planet but
his fight with khabib never came to
fruition
to knock out a man of that stature a man
who's a first ballot Hall of Famer in
the UFC
to knock out a man we call El Cucuy
we're talking about Tony Ferguson what
Michael Chandler did to Tony Ferguson
was downright disrespectful you're gonna
Spartan Kick this man after all the wars
that he's given you all the
entertainment are you not entertained
Michael Chandler said
let me kick you right in the face
Spartan Style Spartan 300 style it's The
Knockout of the year because of who
these two gentlemen are the card
placement the magnitude of The Knockout
who he knocked out so congratulations to
our boy that thick boy himself Michael
Chandler the most entertaining BMF dude
on the planet walking the streets of
that great city of Nashville right now
so knockout of the year goes to my boy
Michael Chandler for his vicious KO over
the first ballot Hall of Famer Tony
Ferguson congrats
your words in the mail when I sat down
in the room with Hunter Campbell and had
that phone call with Dana White it was
almost two years ago at this point I
said I want to be a good thing for your
organization I want to come in and do
exactly what I said I was going to do
which was come in either prove I am who
I am right away or sink or swim and then
I could have came in went 0-2 and got
cut but here we are and uh dude I'm
having a blast here we are coming off a
freaking Spartan Kick KO one of the
might be the best kill of the year it's
uh it's in the front runner right now
you know so it's Tony Ferguson yeah so
who's never been ko'd before he's been
tko'd but never flat I like that so I
mean it was it was good man the thing
about that fight too it's not like it
was like like Tony was looked good
that's the thing it wasn't like this
like watered-down version of Tony
Ferguson I mean granted he has his
flight miles on him yeah it's still Tony
Ferguson he's Tony Ferguson he's
extremely tough so you had to be willing
to get settled in for a 15-minute War
that's what I was prepared for and
obviously that first round he tagged me
a couple times he's
he's awkwardly long and moves awkwardly
yeah he didn't even hit me with the sand
he didn't hit me with any like you know
the crazy Tony stuff but just the way
that he moves his mannerisms they're
different than anybody else you're
training with in the gym so you kind of
had to go in there and make decisions on
the Fly and I kind of threw that kick
went on a wing in a prayer up the middle
I don't think I've ever seen you do that
no I don't do it a lot and I I swearing
I swear I can't I can't tell if I'm
actually if I do remember thinking let's
see if this works or if I watch the
replay and I think that's what I was
thinking in the moment but because I
knew because Tony had his hands kind of
here and his elbows were out so I knew
there was a lane up the middle and I
wanted to wanted to threaten the
takedown go high Go Logo uppercut in the
middle obviously on my hands heavy guy
but I was like let's see if this works
and then all of a sudden oh it worked
he's on the ground I'm doing back two of
the year now moving on
there's a knockout you got to do
submission here so our submission of the
year
now think boy
staff give me a little biased we have
our favorites and I think this Show's
hair okay there's a lot of great
submissions some fantastic submissions
of course Gordon Ryan should probably
win this award no matter what but we're
talking about UFC here Gordon Ryan's not
in the UFC so save it but Gordon Ryan is
the greatest walking Jiu Jitsu
practitioner on the face of the planet
but he's not in this category because
this we're talking MMA we're talking tip
of the spirit UFC submissions all right
and it goes to my boy the great last
white American hope
the man is world renowned for his
wrestling at Penn State University he's
one of my favorite guests of all time at
Food Truck Diaries there's just
something about this dude this is a guy
who was fighting on Dana White's
Contender series and his in his first
fight wanted uh homside
unless you say he's out of his mind I
disagree you can't look at his fighting
style look at homs out look at the other
middleweights on the world and go it's
been a tough fight for anybody that's
how talented this kid is this type of
talent from Bo nickel comes around once
a lifetime so he got our submission of
the year and it happened not in the UFC
but on Dana White's Contender series all
right again he can get it done he's only
a blue belt I told him on the show you
need to tell your coach blue belts don't
transition like that in inverted
triangles into arm bars that would be
the best blue belt that's ever walked
this Earth you're not a blue belt bow
quit sandbagging you black belt just
need to put your time in it's only a
matter of time but before you get your
black belt let me give you the official
thick boy MMA award chain for submission
of the Year congrats to Bo nickel I'm
sharing you a lot more Hardware not just
from thick boy but from around the world
including that UFC gold championship
belt keep doing the damn thing I can't
wait for your debut fight in the UFC in
2023 I'm looking forward most of that
and Jon Jones coming back it's one and
two one a one 1B but that's how
important Bo nickel is for the UFC so
congrats Bo nickel enjoy the chain my
man it's in the mail your Wikipedia says
your blue belt yeah
what world does who's your coach who's
your coach I'm a black man I don't know
if I control you right now but I'm a
goddamn black belt you are not a blue
belt dude no blue belt moves like that
yeah you'd be there in what 56 seconds
52 seconds whatever under admit it who's
counting here but the transitions you
had three different submissions and then
finally get done with a triangle without
arms without using your hands that ain't
Bluebell dude I don't know who your
coach is but I need to talk to him yeah
well first off shout out to my coach
Marcel Ferreira with American top team
so you know he's been coaching me and
teaching me and stuff so I got to train
a little more in the ghee if I wanna
he's a old school Brazilian dude so I
gotta you know get a few training
sessions one of those guys yeah he's a
great dude great dude so he's I mean I'm
sure he told me I'll be black belt
within like two years or something yeah
so or next week yeah yeah right well
let's just give it to you now you know
let's take a little bit of a break from
giving out all this hardware for the
first ever thick boy Awards if you watch
any show that I do and I do too many I
know I'm exhausted if you do if you
watch the shows you know one product is
on every single set I do I'm about Rogue
nicotine I use the six milligram pouches
they offered three but I absolutely love
these the flavor is second to none
there's nothing else on the market like
Rogue that's why I asked and be part of
this program if you don't like uh the
pouches they have other ways to get your
nicotine they got lozengers they got gum
tablets they got it all I'm a pouch guy
but I'll mix it up from time to time
this week my favorite is the mango but I
have Berry here my absolute all-time
go-to if I don't choose one for the rest
of my life is the Apple Apple's my
absolute favorite and there's no
restrictions I take it on planes
the airport I passed through TSA just
fine taking green rooms the gym on my
bike I take it everywhere podcast
Studios clearly everywhere I go Rogue
nictine is with me I absolutely love
them it's fantastic if you want to try
pouches like your boy here or the gums
or tablets go to Rogue nicotine.com use
the code rogue20 for 20 off your entire
order your boy has a subscription plan
so it shows up at the crib and I have to
worry about running out so you can save
20 off by going to Rogue 20
r-o-g-u-e-20 all right and listen Rogue
is the best of the best it's the best
nicotine on the planet I'm talking about
Rogue Daddy all right underage sales
prohibited warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is addictive chemical
for more information visit
roguenicketing.com that's Rogue 20 for
20 off your entire order go get it
before we get back this ridiculous award
historic award season I'm talking about
the thick boy first annual Awards I'm
here to talk to you about a little thing
called Kratom now when you hear Kratom
what's the first thing you think oh I've
heard you can do some good things was
kind of the Wild West like CBD back in
the day I don't know if I can trust it I
don't know who to trust what's good what
should I take what's not well I'm here
to tell you your One-Stop shop for all
Kratom you can trust your boy uses it
all the time it's the best focused
product on the market and it's safe
absolutely love this product we're
talking about happy hippo I use the
Cherry concentration shot cute little
pink hippos on that boom one of those
privy show your boy is basically Jeff
Bezos I take that one shot boom We're
Off to the Races your brain is firing up
I got CT it helps you even with that
your boy's just spitting facts on the
show thanks to happy hippo if you want
to save 20 off the best Kratom on planet
Earth all you gotta do is visit happy
hippo go to happyhippo.com promo code
thick boy you get 20 suffer life that's
right 20 off the best focused product on
the planet talking happy hippocratum
visit happyhippo.com use the promo code
thick boy you get 20 for Life use that
code as many times you want share with
your friends your family your freaking
Bible study group whoever you're around
you can use that code thick boy for 20
off all right happyhippo.com promo code
thick boy 20 off for life you're welcome
now let's get back to giving out some
awards
all right and next up uh you know one
little wrinkle we put in food truck uh
this year after I left show time we have
to mix it up a little bit you know it to
increase some of the visuals do stuff
like that really focus more on the truck
the food you get to know the trucks it's
all great food
but the little wrinkle that we added in
that made it different from when the
show was on Showtime food truck Diaries
is I'm a sneakerhead so I wanted to make
it more personal and I know not every
fighter that comes on as a sneaker head
but I can try my best so my friends over
at suplex shoes the shoe store in
Philadelphia where I get most of my
kicks from if you see me post kicks
which I post every day on Instagram
stories haven't seen it hashtag
Sneakerhead kicks of the day thick Boy
Studio kicks of the day damn near all
those shoes unless they're from my boy
dabik in New York which aren't Nikes or
Reeboks those are his own brand shout
out to the big but all those shoes you
see on there come from my friends at
suplex that's my plug so I've been
working with them for a while we have a
good working relationship I said hey I
have an idea for food truck how about we
make it personal and I know the stories
of everybody that comes on and we give
them a shoe that represents their story
their Journey they went we love it we're
in so suplex sponsored The Show by
sending each guest a specific pair of
shoes that is tailored created for them
we've had some great shoes my boy uh
who's at Curtis blades which airs uh
soon got the it was a size 16 mind you
that was the toughest one we've ever had
to find we got him the Space Jam Jordan
11s best shoes of all time
um we've gotten some pretty Pretty Fly
shoes out there man some really really
cool shoes the guys from Chicago's were
laced up in Jordans
um we're dropping some Yeezys before all
the stuff before it wasn't cool to wear
Yeezys so they always send fire stuff
and I always kind of pick and choose
what they should send they give me some
ideas but I usually have something in
mind for Francis ingano we got those
dope Sakai they were the color of the
African flag he loved them warm on the
plane he took off I think he's wearing
like Crocs or something like that so
that bummed me out but whatever uh so
there's a lot of shoes to choose from
but this is the most unique shoe that
we've given away I don't it's up there
most valuable it's one of my favorite
shoes I don't have them but my favorite
shoe and it's the next award we're
giving up it's sponsored by super
complex shoes in Philadelphia go check
them out suplex shoe of the Year from
food truck diary goes to my boy sugar
Shawn O'Malley that's right that dude
had one hell of a year he beat the
number one dude on the planet Peter
Young which is not easy he got it done
controversially but he got it done and
we know he should be at the top he can
hang out that level
and sugar is a colorful guy he'll die
his hair all those crazy colors right
looks like a snow cone he'll wear chains
he has his own swag his old Lango he's
on freaking you know twitch doing his
thing the kid has crossed over he he's
he's he's finally his ranking represents
his Fame he's number one so he's number
one in everybody's Hearts he's number
one online this kid is a superstar so
what kind of shoe do you get a superstar
well you get him the J Balvin Jordan
Ones they're not easy to find it took
many weeks to find especially in his
size which is common I think it was like
a nine or ten but these shoes which see
here are so colorful they've never made
a Jordan like these they're these
tie-dye cut up Jordans they're my one of
my favorite Jordans of all time my
number one Jordan of all time is the
union ones the LA versions but
this J Balvin shoe is super unique
this is the only fighter that could rock
this shoe now you will see on social
media sugar Shawn walking into the arena
or doing some promo and Dubai or
something like that you'll notice he's
wearing them he loves them nothing makes
me happier when the athletes the
fighters actually wear the shoes so
that's why I try my best to make sure
it's a fit and boy was I right on this
one so sugar Shawn enjoy being the
number one badass in the world but also
enjoy those J Balvin Jordan Ones because
they are special and I see you rocking
my man it makes me so happy so you
deserve it dude so suplex shoe of the
year goes to my boy none other than
sugar Shawn O'Malley enjoy those J
balvin's my man shout out to suplex
thanks for getting it done this year has
been easy sometimes people give me two
day notice hey I'm in town well come on
food truck my boy Casey's scrambling for
a food truck I could call it suplex hey
you gotta overnight these kicks
hopefully they have them these boys stay
up all night trying to Source the shoe
and we just they always get it done man
so shout out to the team and these are
the most unique and Loud ones and to me
these represent you because you got to
be the most unique guy in the UFC so
these Jordan Ones represent you my man
dude
I feel like they're right up your alley
man and takashi69 is gonna be all over
these
[Applause]
these are the sickest [ __ ] shoes I've
ever seen I love that pink I mean is
that not a sugar
yeah they're so simple not easy to get
they come to appreciate that no problem
yeah thanks for doing the show man so
dope
aren't they dope oh yeah these are
[ __ ] I'm a fan of J Balvin too yeah
they got the smiley face in them dude
they got all the crazy colors they're
the most unique Jordan of all time dude
yeah those are nuts but those are from
me and my friends at suplex in Philly
yes thank you guys hopefully you rock
them of course because you're careful
rocking these bad boy you don't want to
step on these yeah you don't get robbed
either Hollywood's getting a little
dicey man oh dude the different oh
this next award you're not gonna see it
on any of these other MMA award shows
because this is specific to thick boy
Studios and all the content shows we put
out we do a little show called the
Calabasas fight companion which was born
out of the idea of Joe Rogan his fight
campaign my favorite show to do of all
time Joe clearly has gotten too busy we
still do some of them but not at the
rate that I like it's my favorite show
to do it's so much fun so thank God Joe
Rogan gave his Blessing it was his idea
not taking credit he goes you should do
your own I went say less
that shows the toughest show to do on
this network because
with Rogan it was always the same Four
Guys Joe Rogan Eddie Bravo Brian Cal
myself and there's chemistry there and
if you saw the last one we did on uh JRE
even though the four of us haven't
gotten together in years probably four
years it doesn't matter when we get
together it's magic it's the perfect
casting for fight companions
the issue I have in Calabasas is it's
not the same staff I decided to put a
little Wrinkle In It by choice and mix
it up every time so uh you had some guys
returning like Josh Thompson shout out
to Josh Thompson who was amazing on
fight campaign you had Matt mitrion
who's on their Bunch you had Rampage
Jackson this last one we did a collab
with bar stool for the rough and rowdy
and you had uh the most random one we've
ever had Teddy swims
um you had uh Adam 22 from no jumper
yeah Donald Cerrone and Rampage Jackson
then the next night you had Sam tripley
Brian Cowan Frank Grillo we're
constantly mixing up we've got Brian
Ortega his girl on there
um what'd you say Tracy Cortez yep Tracy
Cortez who's an absolute monster and
Dime Piece
um you we've had all sorts of characters
on there man
um so this next award and we have a
trophy inside thick boy Studios and they
don't get the trophy it's kind of like
the Stanley Cup we take it back after
but we let you know who won so for every
episode that we do on fight companion oh
we also had my boy Jesse from Jessie on
fire was on there Frank Mayer you know
we've had some great ones man it's been
so much fun but
again they don't take the awards like
Stanley Cup we just add their name to
the side of it like the Stanley Cup and
we keep it here and we add their names
so we have that here in studio
but
we pick one for each individual episode
but the thick boy Awards annual Awards
season this is our first one so be cool
we're doing the DMF of the year and it
goes to Rampage Jackson now DMF just
like the BMF title stands for drunkest
mother
trucker they're only getting demonetized
drunkest mother trucker put enough for
the
replace the the the T with the F right
drunkest mother trucker of the year
and he came in late he came in late he
was behind a little bit and then this
dude just rallied and on our fight
campaign we did for Barstool Sports for
rough and rowdy 19. my boy Rampage
Jackson Takes the Cake now Josh Thompson
a close second
Josh Thompson close second now he came
this out badass Josh Thompson is he was
doing a a broadcast rebellator in Dublin
flew all the way from Dublin to
Calabasas just to make the fight
campaign flew through the night and
decided to stay up and drink so when he
landed here he's already drank he's
already drank it he's already drunk he's
only drink he already drank he only
drink he was already drunk but he
continued to drink and it got pretty
Saucy it was fun he got Saucy but nobody
was more entertaining when he's drunk
than Rampage Jackson and he loved tiger
thank you so he's so smooth man we have
so many videos him being crazy with
tiger thinking I don't know if you pay
attention during the broadcast that dude
finished a bottle took two bottles home
asked me to ship him some to his house
now all the time so he's a fan of tiger
thick which I appreciate but Rampage
he's one of those drunks that gets super
fun talked about butt play for an hour
uh how he doesn't enjoy it start telling
all these crazy stories and off here got
even more raunchy he's one of my
favorites to ever do it this dude should
have his own podcast Rampage was my
favorite people on the planet and it is
my pleasure to give Rampage Jackson the
DMF of the Year from thick boy Studios
the drunkest mother trucker of the year
on calabas's fight campaign Goes To None
other than my boy the legend himself
Rampage Jackson now that Chain's gonna
look good on him he's Mr Chain man so
this thing is thick too it's like a big
Cuban Link you'll see it they're fly man
we ain't giving out belts we're giving
out chains like Drake
big tiger
are you gonna wait tiger thick
that's how drunk I am it's all good guys
that's easy to mix up it should be
called thick tiger [ __ ] [ __ ] Mr swab you
ever look at a tiger and just think damn
damn
horses like [ __ ] even though you get
even though you get buzzed you don't
want to stop that's how smooth it is
like I should have stopped like two
hours ago
your wiener and then it's still going
when I talked about it I enjoy it no no
I'm glad
what else are you gonna tell us you're
going to give me a bottle of this right
yeah and I can buy this at any liquor
store after that you can get at thick
boy.com thick boy.com I gotta go to
thickboy.com not you I'll send it to you
yes sir you can take it all night Austin
see you send a thick boy a bottle yeah I
should probably send him a bottle yeah
you guys see him that's the handwritten
thank you that's the move yeah even
though he got knocked out thank you he
got he got knocked out he didn't get I
mean yeah yeah no no no he lost that
fight oh yeah he lost the fight he
didn't get back up which is weird he
looks so good boy are you gonna get a
bottle a handwritten thank you note and
then a uh Christmas five percent off for
your family uh for the merch yeah very
realistic hand-drawn illustration of
rampage's [ __ ] no it's his [ __ ] yeah
the
um
too much of it I'm like wasting all his
bottles it's so good it's like it's
based off of that Japanese style whiskey
right what the [ __ ] you got me with the
Japanese whiskey you got me with the
Japanese I knew it would get you [ __ ]
even though you're dating a white girl
now I knew you'd come back yeah come
back around to the come back to the
Asians yep come back today you're sold
the thick boy Studios shows are very
fight heavy so this next award is Best
Bet of the a year best day of the year
funniest bit of the year uh the whole
staff voted on this and you're gonna get
your best bits on Kyle bass fight
campaign because I usually load it up
with comics and clearly Comics can be
funnier than fighters in general unless
it's Rampage you as a gift mattrion had
some great lines too but
Josh Barnett was great
um I understand how all the people we've
had man insane but uh
this award is special to me it's the
best bit of the year on Cowboys fight
companion and it goes to none other the
man who provides a bump we're talking
about Chris Delia Chris Delia
when he first came on fighting Man's
first show he ever did after a long
layoff and he's one of the first fight
companions over a million views he comes
back on combat's fight campaign to help
his boy out and it was such a good time
I got him and Brian Callan together back
together after years and when he
transformed himself into this weird like
pterodactyl far right Eagle saying don't
push me we I could not stop laughing her
enough it was my favorite bit of the
year it was so spot-on especially during
the current climate that we're living in
it was so funny with your left all right
that's funny man so bit of the year goes
to my boy Chris Dalia the ugly Eagle
himself the funniest dude on the planet
him or Theo nobody makes me laugh harder
in person they're so freaking talented
so Crystal and he will rock this chain I
guarantee it so uh we'll see him soon so
crystalia my man you know I love you
enjoy your thick boy annual MMA award
even though you don't even know a thing
or two about fighting you provide great
comedy laughter you're entertaining we
don't care if you know about fighting
you bring so much to the table when it
comes to the fight campaign so we love
you man and you get it uh best bit of
the Year thick boy award for your don't
push me to the far right pit on cow bass
fight campaign so chain is in the mail
in the mail I'll just give it to you I
see it how about that all right this
[ __ ] these masks are hilarious just
[Music]
you see Dublin dropped all sanctions
today in England really Dublin dropped
it today Ireland I wish they would do in
Russia you know when we go home
[Music]
we're gonna visit but um yeah dude I go
to the I go to you know I go to the
Coffee Bean which one I go all you know
there's a few of them right like that I
switch it up depending on if going to
the valley if I'm going to the [ __ ]
weho side it doesn't matter but I go to
get coffee bean and I go in every day I
go in with the message I go in with the
with the mask on okay and I go in with
the mask on because I you know what I'll
play the game right if you want me to
wear the mask I don't want people to be
uncomfortable around me we have to play
the game though no I understand I'm
playing the game I play the game but
even in the valley they want you to wear
their mask I wear the mask every day and
look I had kovid I don't have it right
now I know I don't and I'm vaxxed okay
so I put the mask on other people so I
put the mask on
listen to me
out of respect yourself oh [ __ ] so I got
the mask on and I go in and and I
realize I don't my mask broke right ping
oh that's it Jesus Christ oh my God ping
ping ping ping what's up that's what I
do if I'm in the fighters if I'm not a
fighter oh he puts them off pretty rough
that guy that's a weird time for a hug
that guy's great no that guy was [ __ ]
up that's all right I'm fine um big cup
huh so I [ __ ] go in I don't have the
mask because it broke and I walk in with
my shirt I I'm I play I play the game
right I'm I played that's not the game
though that's not the game but I don't
have it so I'm so so I'm like so let me
work with them right I'm not gonna walk
in I don't have it hey I don't have it
[ __ ] off let me play the game right yeah
I want you to be comfortable around me
so I walk in I do this I put my hand
over the [ __ ] right yep Like An Outlaw
exactly like I'm going to rob the place
but it's also fresh but it's past 2019
so everyone knows I'm not gonna Rob the
place they know that maybe I'm being
nice about the coronavirus okay yeah
you're about to interrupt me don't do it
okay man so I walk in and I say to the
guy can I get a coffee and I said
Americano they know me every day and
they say actually do you have a mask and
I say no but I got my shirt over my
thing and my hand over my thing so it
should be all good and they say you need
a mask and I say well let me just get
the coffee real quick and I'll leave
it'll be fine it doesn't work and then
the guy it does work like that but there
are saying it doesn't I agree let's work
like things in my face but they're
saying it does you shouldn't Point too
hard because it does work like that
acting like we work for you but they're
saying it doesn't right okay so now I'm
like well I have my hand and [ __ ] all
over the [ __ ] and the shirt over this
[ __ ] certainly it's fine and the guy
says you need to have a mask that covers
your ears that's what he said and I'll
never forget it okay so I said to him
well okay I need a mask during this
pandemic that covers my ears and he said
well you need one of these masks
conversational TKO right I murdered him
with just repeating what he said so I
said well I don't have one and they said
sorry
a nice lady said I have an extra one in
my car so I said oh that would be
awesome if you'd let me have it she said
come on gets the car gets the mess of
the car puts on I go like this and I say
I'd like one iced Americano because now
I have a mask that covers my ears and
she says okay she Rings it up and in
reach there are four people with no mask
on allowed to be there oh why because
they're holding a sandwich
dude oh yes because they're eating work
with me here if I forget my mask
work with me dude
on your side
why are you pushing me over to the right
Chrissy are you going over the right you
go come on over I'm a gentrist
with me
Chris don't go to the door I'm on your
team don't go too far to the right
let me get an apology out of him they're
only extreme right now we only stream
right Chris Chris
I want extreme right Chris I don't even
recognize your face I'll rip That
vaccine right out of my shoulder oh God
I'll spread election fraud oh God Joe
Biden is a lizard
Chris come back to us man let's go shoot
up Comet Pizza hey come back come more
to the center you've got it right Chris
he's drooling God right because I don't
even recognize your face right Chris has
rabies check her emails Chris that's all
over you've got
it's not over she's not locked up
that's exactly
oh
I'm spizzing on us
it's crashing always he's crashed he's a
giant right Bird ah [ __ ] man both my
tear lowered oh man I'm sweating oh God
yeah right Chris is [ __ ] terrible oh
[ __ ] sorry dude man it's great you're
right I'm glad I'm back man take that go
Brandon Coffee Bean and Tea Leaf work
with Chris work with me man you don't
want to nudge me I know
McGinnis
[Laughter]
man right Chris's Newsom is ruining the
economy well I think that's left and
right saying that
yeah never mind
um next award uh don't worry we don't
have a few more this is just a seven
hour it's like the Oscars I'm gonna I
should have put on a tuxedo or at least
a suit I didn't think about that so I'm
guessing like the oldest [ __ ]
hypebeast of all time I do have red
lobsters on be cool
um the next award listen
there's no food truck without the truck
so we go through a lot of trucks and we
try to mix it up every time but if it's
a really good truck and if they're
Dependable because a lot of these trucks
you know they're not in calabasa if they
drive up from La so if we get a truck
that goes man use this anytime you want
so if we're in a pinch uh you know like
when we had uh Alex volkanovski on I was
on an eight-hour notice and he was like
I can do it on Sundays Sundays I don't
work on the Lord's day it's only day I
have off to rest and be with my family
the entire day so I never I hate to work
on Sundays but when the champ the pound
for pound champ Alex volcanovskios I'm
in town I can only do Sunday we made it
happen
and one of the trucks that comes through
for us all the time when we're in a
pinch is a truck called trapping wings I
love chicken wings my favorite food so
the first ever food truck of the year
goes to trap and wings they're fantastic
Wings you see them all over La try them
out they're some of the best wings you
will ever ever have whether it's a brick
and mortar restaurant or a food truck
trap and wings is no freaking joke and
it's my favorite food truck we've had
them or Cousins lobster rolls but
trapping wings for wings
that you go to so food truck of the year
for thick boy studies award goes to trap
and Wing shout to trap and wings thank
you guys for the support thank you for
providing the best tasting Wings on the
planet we love you guys shout out to
trapping Wings your award is in the mail
or I can skip to you next time I do a
food truck and put it on you that could
be cool too
[Music]
I always question the appropriate
etiquette and technique of eating
because yeah deep throat that thing yeah
exactly I mean
I did that with one motion of my mouth
yeah gets as long as we don't look each
other in the eye okay then you're good
because I was proud of you lock eyes
dude bro yeah you've done for this
country it's the least I can
besides you oh this was all I was
waiting for
start looking up uh Mel's movies just
until buy time till the wings came
all right so this looks like all right
that's the baby mama barbecue that's the
parmesan
oh here we go yeah uh so the saw 60 well
so he just labeled them and tell which
ones that's pretty easy though I would
assume that's the sausage before yep
that's lemon pepper mango habanero yes
fire top to bottom right to left all
right it's like we're ready 164. that's
where you're gonna start yeah man that's
what the guy was said you know he like
whispered us the flavoring
get down in there just gonna rub the
bottom
get it on the nose a little bit
oh it's spicy
I know we I know we what is that no I
wasn't expecting that um
it's definitely a secret
it's like it's nice at the end there is
that black pepper oh that's where the
spice is coming from there's like sweet
when I got on there I just want to bite
this guy who's this skinny woman we just
walked in
shredded we got wings for days for each
the next award this is a fun one next
award is thick boy of the year now thick
is in the heart not in your arteries
thick is in the heart not everybody has
to be thick to be a thick boy thick boy
is a lifestyle it's in the heart I'm not
talking about your cholesterol or your
arteries
talking about a lifestyle maybe maybe
work your ass off and you're shredded
but you worked that hard to eat a donut
that's a thick boy maybe you can run a
sub six minute mile and just doing it so
you can get a milkshake that's a thick
boy all right for all those thick dads
out there you feel me now thick boy of
the year goes to my boy Chris Barnett
and Chris Barnett AKA Beast Boy is the
most athletic 300 pounder you will ever
see in your life and he can dance his
ass off Chris Barnett represents
everything thick boy is about is a
positive attitude he does engage with
any any hate he doesn't engage with
anything negative when this dude has
every reason to feel sorry for himself
and if you watch the food truck I cried
on it it's one of the few few food
trucks that I cried on his story and
losing his wife and being this good dad
and his mom and dad and just the way he
came up and his brother and his sister
he is such a good person I cannot say
enough good things about Chris Barnett
hopefully he's in Georgia right now
enjoying some barbecue this holiday
season but our first ever thick boy of
the year goes to the one and only Beast
Boy he's one of the most exciting
fighters in the UFC in the heavyweight
division anytime he fights you should be
tuning in because you never know what
you're going to get I guarantee you're
not going to see a thick man move like
Chris Barnett let's do it is so gifted
but even what precedes his freaking
gifts and talents is his heart and it's
not thick but it is made of gold shout
out to Chris Barnett he's our thick boy
of the year go watch the food truck if
you haven't seen it it's by far top two
food trucks I've ever done Chris Barnett
is a fantastic human being so enjoy the
award my man you're the first ever
annual thick boy of the Year Chris
Barnett this boy sorry what's up big dog
appreciate you having me sir dude I
wanted you on here the minute you won
that fight when you did that big thick
boy and people were tagging us being
like you guys need to spawn some the
first thick boy athlete that's it we
need that front flip I was like I hit my
I might get a hold of him right now
right this second there's a deeper
passion now like to get the
the notes and stuff actually like this
morning just going through Instagram hey
man I just want to let you know you
always have a house here in Scotland I
didn't know what I wanted to do with
myself I saw you you just made me smile
yeah I made it through my day and I was
like yeah it's dope you right there man
I'll be right there I'm never coming
soon
I'm actually never gonna be in Scotland
but never
we got a car to Vegas yeah so in regards
to making weight obviously you have to
cut the 265 how big of a issue is that
for you is it pretty easy yeah like
literally that was one of the reasons
why the UFC didn't sign me at first
because I was 320. I never liked cut
ain't no way you're gonna make the cut
you know I mean so I made it a couple of
times earlier in the career and then
honestly that Japan thing came around
and they were like we want you as big as
possible if you can still do the stuff
you do I said say less I think I was
like 350 when I fought Traverse view
yeah man like and you can you can just
views uh second round TKO next award
almost down here we got two more kids
next award goes to M A MMA content
creator of the year now a lot went into
this because of course there's the big
dogs out there MMA junkie share dog if
you're from 1998 but they're still doing
the thing you got cheer dog MMA junkie
MMA fighting uh
um morning combat morning combat shout
out to Luke Thomas and Brian Campbell I
can't give it to them they're too big
they're they're in the big leagues now
you're not gonna get this award from me
you guys are bigger than us we can't do
that that ain't cool you can't do that
that's like some up and coming rapper
giving Drake an award he's like thanks
dude and then pee on it we can't have
that everybody I mentioned are the best
of the best in the business you got Ben
folks you got freaking
um Brett akamato uh at ESPN obviously
here hawani has won the MMA award for
journalists of the year I don't know 15
times 13. you win so many and when I
want to listen to MMA content
I listened to a few of them if I'm if
I'm trying to come up with different
angles I'll listen to the angles that
are out there and then try to come up
with something different or I don't want
to hear it because it might swayed my
opinion in a different way but if I'm
struggling with something I will depend
on four shows
um Michael bisping's great he could win
MMA content creator of the year Michael
Bisping is fantastic Chael sonen clearly
fantastic again they're bigger than me
they're big dogs they're not going to
win this award so if you're too big
you're out of the running I should say
up and counter MMA content creator of
the year so Michael Bisping chill
sounding they're out irwani I don't
watch the MMA hour obviously hates me I
still understand I like I actually like
the guy but my favorite MMA show I think
to surprise you guys is iru Hawaii show
he does with uh Chuck Mendenhall and the
British dude
a free of the British dude's name
um but there's three of them it's uh the
ringer it's on spot I think it's only on
Spotify but they do it right after the
event and you're talking about three of
the best
journalists in the game but by far by
far the three three of the best and
these three Talking Heads get in there
the ringer MMA show
what'd you say is it pizza Carol yes
okay Carol and he always he always calls
in from I think he lives in England he
lives in England he's a big uh Tom
aspenhoff fan and Patty pamlett fan and
his take on Patty pimlet because he's
he's in London is second to none he just
he he gives you the the down low on how
the MMA fan base in London it's not it's
the Golden Ages he said it's the golden
age right now of uh uh British MMA uh
Europe MMA London MMA he's saying how
Patty after this last fight he's kind of
changed the narrative how upset people
are about kind of what he's doing so
that's pizza Carol right there he's a
Savage and he pairs up with arrow hawani
and Chuck Mendenhall and it's just three
smart dudes way smarter than me talking
about MMA and they know the ins and outs
of MMA even though none of them have
fought doesn't matter these dudes are
the Stephen A Smith of our Sport and uh
it's my favorite show to watch but I
can't give it to them you can't give to
them they're bigger than me they're too
big now I can give a thick boy award so
I got as fellas I want to give you the
word but I can't
so my MMA creator also shout out to my
boys uh Luke Thomas and Brian Campbell
um you know they did win the MMA award
the official Awards this is official to
you bastards this is official but they
won I'm so proud of those guys me and
Luke Thomas go way way back there's
nobody that I'm closer to at MMA than
Luke Thomas I absolutely adore the guy
he's so goddamn smart his knowledge on
MMA when he breaks it down there's none
better he's so good I love Luke Thomas
Luke you're bigger than me you're not
getting the award you're not getting the
award you have the award in my heart
okay
but as far as Hardware goes and the next
up-and-comer he's me right there with
you guys
is my boy Jesse on fire
if you've
ever seen any of his content this dude
puts out video on video and as a content
creator myself I know how hard that is
to do this dude's constantly putting out
videos uh he's almost at 100 000
subscribers he's self-made self-taught
self-educated with all this stuff he's
editing himself up on the audio doing
the edits the thumbnails he does it all
writes all his material this is a
one-man Army he's the best in the
business to do it he's the next up and
comer he's almost at 100 000 subscribers
on his own you know how hard that is to
do as an MMA content creator to get to
100 000 this dude is a Savage he has a
work ethic that I've never seen he's one
of my favorites to watch he'll get into
the dicing material he's must see TV
this award was easy for me to pick
because I'm not going with the big dogs
like everybody else I'm going to the
next up and coming Jesse on fire
congrats my man your thick boys MMA
content creator of the Year enjoy it
your Chain's in the mail your Chain's in
the mail my man Connor needs a win
and I think that if anybody has any
experience handicapping fights even
though Conor's been out for a long time
they can pray say pretty safely Conor is
going to be a massive favorite in that
fight a massive favorite in that fight
Patty gets punched Connor is exceptional
at punching people even if they don't
really get punched a lot themselves so
the likelihood that Patty is going to
survive a five-round fight with Connor
getting dotted up like he would is
extraordinarily hard to you know picture
so Connor's almost certainly going to
get a win and he's going to get a big
win with everyone watching
everyone watching the entire universe
will watch this fight because Patty is a
massive draw and he's also exceptional
promoting fights he's fun dude all right
we're at the end kids our final award is
guest of the year
and you know the shop show isn't guest
driven at all it's just me rant into the
camera for an hour
food truck is heavy guest driven cow
bass fight campaign heavy guest driven
uh Fight Night flashbacks guest driven
so the only show that doesn't contain
Gast is the shop show that's how we you
know created this so nothing's hardened
what I do than booking guests it's the
nightmare we have people that help but
still a nightmare um people fall out
they cancel the day of it's a nightmare
but
my favorite guest of the year he's a
controversial guy right now but I know
he has a great heart and he's a great
fighter and we just got to give him time
and I think he'll leave up to the hype
this is one of the few guests I've only
driven for two guests I've only left my
home studio for two guests ever Mike
Tyson and I did uh I co-hosted his
hotboxing show with Francis ingano at a
Super Bowl show for him and then he was
on food truck I drove to him we drove to
him in uh was that Redondo area where
his uh Tyson Ranch is at so I did a food
truck with Mike Tyson which was so
interesting so fun shot the legend Mike
Tyson
and then the other person that I
traveled for which usually I'm if
someone wants me to travel I don't do it
I do it for very few people but the next
gentleman is somebody who I don't know
what to expect obviously I've been
familiar with him for a hot second
um it's Patty pimlet so we drove to San
Diego uh Patty had other obligations and
couldn't get down to Calabasas so he's
like man I want to do it and his
manager's like does anybody can come to
us we've never we've only done for Mike
Tyson wasn't that far San Diego's a
track let me talk to the team let me try
and find a food truck out there things
came together I said we need a venue uh
a club I perform at all the time uh down
there is the Laugh Factory San Diego a
new club down there in the heart of The
Gaslight District in San Diego so I
called uh Laugh Factory I said hey I
need to do a sit-down interview with
this uh pretty big name in the sport can
you guys open during the day it's like
whenever open during the day I'm like
please open for me so my friends at the
Laugh Factory San Diego made it happen
so we're able to use that venue we got
this phenomenal food truck do you
remember the name of it it's burgers
wagyu Burgers wagyu right fantastic so
when I drive down there again I've never
met Patty before this
within the first five minutes I'm like
oh I get it
I get it this kid is
um special this kid's super super
special it might be our biggest food
truck on the thick Boy network it's at
560 000 views
um you know when I was with Showtime we
have some over a million probably 10 of
them over a million but we're new we're
about you know we'll be like I said
we're 11 months old now so 560 ain't bad
so that's the bump of Patty pimlet
um when we do the interview you'll see
this is thick Patty this is Patty who uh
put on some weight which he does between
the shows and uh swag you that's a swag
you truck swagu so shout out to swagoo
Burger truck one of my favorite trucks
Patty ate I think four burgers
I had one
I'm 245 pounds Patty had four of them
and uh the interview he's like you have
much time as you want so we're doing our
thing we're talking between shots stuff
like that I can't believe he was
watching you all right man if you have
to get at her we're good we don't need
to keep going he's like Liverpool plays
oh Liverpool mate Liverpool mates I need
to go down to the pub I'm like oh [ __ ]
you know that's right you guys are balls
deep into football out there so um this
kid just has it he's such a good person
that's why I defend the kid at all cost
his last fight nobody got robbed should
he have won I don't know it's a close
call
close close call but nobody got robbed
it's just he's so famous he's going to
get a lot more hate than other Fighters
because you guys don't think he deserves
it I disagree I think his kid Just Gotta
Give time and he will be the champion
that you guys are all hoping that he
becomes you can see even on the ring he
didn't know someone's gonna record that
and blast it out when he's walking the
dog the dog took a poop in the yard and
he brings things like hey my bad that's
what kind of person Patty is he's such a
good person so put your hate towards the
judges not Patty he did his job he went
in there did his best just so happens
two out of three judges thought he won
that fight all good let's all move on
he's a young kid I think he's only 26-27
stop the hate man this kid has it but
you're gonna damage him if you keep
throwing all this toxic [ __ ] his way
you're gonna ruin and you miss out on a
great thing Patty is I'm telling you we
haven't had somebody as good on camera
in a long time since probably Conor
McGregor Tyson Fury he's right up there
with them on camera he's the only
fighter I've ever had on food truck when
he was doing a promo or hyping something
up most people are a little nervous that
they're not educated enough in marketing
and the way shoots work dude he would do
I've never seen this never seen this
Comics would do it if they're if they've
been entertained for a while he would do
the promo to the camera he'd go which
one's my camera boom and not look at me
you'd look into the camera and rip that
promo insane dude as entertaining as
they get you got to give them time this
kid has it so for my guest of the year
and the biggest food truck that we've
had on this network it goes to none
other than the fifth Beetle himself
Liverpool's finest Patty pimlin good
luck to you my man audemia or Texture
where to send the award but it is coming
outside
it makes me laugh when people are
commenting on my stuff and things say
your name uh he's not active enough he
doesn't fight enough he only he should
be fighting four times a year why why
should I fight four times a year
Give Me A Reason when I'm in and more
outside the caves and I am in it you've
earned that
yeah you've earned that but also you'll
see with the the MMA fan base especially
UFC fan base there's going to be
pressure on you to oh we want to see you
against this top five guy or this top 10
guy I mean you know your manager
definitely knows he's dealing with his
background you just gotta not
ignore all that they're going to want to
see you against the chance I have people
treating me in the past few weeks say
you know we want to see you invest
Market Jeff we want to see invest
Ferguson we want to see investigation
I'm like what
I'll be fighting them for about three
years or something and that's if they're
still at the top of the game I think
yeah by then like there's no point no
there isn't it just getting started
there's again it's there's no Sprint
here you'll have a long career man you
got smart people around you you'll be
fine man the fans don't always see that
though they just like I don't want to
see this I want to see that you don't
understand it like you want to see you
want to see fight song There's a fight I
get it they want to see you versus other
really popular fighters but they're also
the same people who buy tickets and
they're sitting there going rip his head
off yeah all right well all right the
one I always get is we want to see your
fight sugar show on O'Malley and I'm
like
so there's no way that fights happens
but it still gets tweeted to me
multiple times are we they just don't
understand it and both of you guys are
kind of in a similar Lane where he's so
polarizing so popular even outside the
Octagon yeah you're the same so it's
like for them it's like oh this makes
sense yeah but it doesn't it doesn't
it's way bigger than it was way big like
way bigger than what way you and I would
have a tussle right yeah it'd be a
problem
well I don't want you to get over 200
pounds but I am going to feed you some
good food man this this game recommended
this looks heavy dude as we say we're
about four years now and we it's rare we
do destination food trucks yeah so I
have to you know in La I have my
connection on food trucks San Diego I'm
not from here I don't so I went on said
hey I didn't tell people you're coming I
go hey we got a big gas I need a food
truck in San Diego I would say we got a
150 requests it'll get swagoo it's our
favorite food truck yeah you're swago so
I'm feeding some swagu burgers man but
you can't eat like seven of them right I
don't be responsible DFC customers
see that's another one I won't be taking
off short notices
what's that happening I don't need to
take the short noses fight all these
people that need to jump on
opportunities with fingernails you don't
take them short notice fights I don't
need to I'm a big enough Star as it is
without taking fights on seven days
notice and killing myself I've had crap
yeah you don't need them I don't need
you too loud I don't need to take short
Lotus fights so when people say to me I
should take this fight on short notice
why that's the awards that's it don't do
this too long on how long we've been
going but uh first ever annual thick boy
Awards congrats to all the winners
congrats to
um you know everybody even if you don't
win award everybody on fight companion
everybody we had Rob Dyrdek on fight
companion with my favorites
um you know food truck Diaries uh Fight
Night flashbacks and the shop show thank
you guys for thanks to the fans you know
for for me taking this risk and leaving
Showtime having a cushy easy gig and
becoming a
a CEO you know heavy lies the crown man
there's a lot more that goes into it
than and I'm learning as I go man but I
absolutely love it and we're just
getting started we're barely a we'll be
a year old like I told you guys January
like 7th or 8th so a year in 160 000
Subs getting some good freaking guests
on launched a bunch of new shows some
worked some didn't that's the way this
goes we got the right staff shout out to
the staff Casey chin the the the the men
behind the camera and the mics here who
put all this together for you guys shout
out to Mike and the Two Georges who have
a fight coming up January 7th
um you know Mark Harley
um I forget anybody Nick Davis on Golden
hour
um
that's it that's our crew right it's so
sad if we missed one person it's a small
team dude it's a small team I mean Tom
who booked it yeah Tara deals with all
social media
um
I think that's it
yeah George's case Ben pixels
that's it I hope I'm not forgetting
anybody if I did WOW Wrigley that's it
Wrigley Wrigley is the mascot of thick
boy Studios this little skinny thing he
looks like Santa's Little Helper from
Simpsons but black he's fantastic he
looks like a seal a little dog I don't
trust him but whatever
um yeah so really biggest thank you goes
to the fans for you know I had so much
anxiety doing this and leaving show time
which I know that was probably the smart
thing to do but in the long run owning
everything doing it yourself I've always
bet on myself it seems to always work
out
um I have a lot more work to do trust me
I know but we're on the right track I
have the right team I always tell these
guys like when Steve Jobs I'm not
comparing myself Steve Jobs I'm giving
you guys an example when Steve Jobs
started Apple was a small team but that
team cared so much about the business
they all made it and obviously they're
all Scrooge McDuck and Steve Job dies of
cancer but I'm sure I'm right behind him
on that with all the [ __ ] I do but
um
the thing is is we have a small team and
there's no machetes here everybody has
to be Swiss Army knives some get this
but everyone has to get the work done so
we have the right team the right staff
in place we're grinding the work ethic
is not ever an issue here I don't hire
anybody who's lazy uh we're actually
looking for a YouTube expert as we speak
so if you are a YouTube expert I don't
mean you know YouTube and you upload
your own shows and you can edit no no
I'm talking you know the algorithm the
ins and outs the thumbnails all that
stuff analytics all the analytics the
behind the scenes the the reels all that
[ __ ] if you know that business or you
worked at uh YouTube or you're currently
at YouTube and you're looking for a
badass job with a lot of freedom a lot
of creativity you want to be part of
something special and You Want To Make
History come to thick boy DM me I'll see
it and we will get back to you I'm
looking for a real dog when it comes to
that stuff if you're a dog and you have
work ethic and you play well with others
DM me we need you DM me man because
we're doing some special [ __ ] here if
you want to be part of something special
DM me don't DM me if you're like well I
like YouTube and it'd be sounds fun
that's not what it is I'm talking legit
bona fide YouTube expert knows the
analytics editing cutting thumbnails
reels those ones to post shorts all that
[ __ ]
DM me be a badass though don't come at
me with oh my sister knows no no I'm
Legit badass YouTube expert
come join the squad come be part of
something special DM me we're looking
for it so that's it man but again I want
to wrap this up I want to thank all the
fans you make you give me a job you buy
my tickets on my tour you watch all the
videos that's how we get sponsors that's
how you keep the house lights on I want
to thank every single one of you that
subscribed to thick boy this year if you
haven't subscribed please go subscribe
nothing make me happier than getting to
200 000 soon so that's the move next
three months get to 200 000 subscribers
um that'd be fantastic that's the way
you show me love I don't ask for
anything else I don't charge for any of
this [ __ ]
that's how you show me love so um let's
get to 200 000 keep the comments popping
the Tiger's thick whiskey we'll talk
about another time but that thing blows
my mind how much support we have on that
and it's winning Awards which absolutely
blows me out of the water so it's all
because of the fans I absolutely love
you guys I'm telling you can trust me
you can bet on me I'm the horse to bet
on I'm gonna work my ass off for you
guys thank you so much for making this
one the most memorable years I've ever
had I've learned so much there's so much
work to do but I humbly tell you guys I
can't thank you enough I absolutely
adore you I love you you see me on the
street I'm not that guy you can't come
up to come talk to me come say what's up
I'm that guy so thank you guys so much
let's get 200 000 Subs I love you guys
thank you for everything liking
subscribing family subscribe tell your
buddy tell your scissors tell your gay
Aunt tell your cousins let's get 200 000
that would just make me so happy we also
I almost forgot we almost I launched my
own freaking special on thick Boy
network
talk about balls I turned out some big
boys I won't name the the companies I
turned out turned down was I'm a better
myself we're right under 2 million views
which is insane I didn't think we'd
cross 400 000 not even close so you guys
just surprised me all the time I love
you guys so much thank you so goddamn
much and uh 2023 is gonna be a big year
man we're just getting started baby and
so to all the winners congrats your
chain is the mail for those of you that
have really close relationship with I
will just hand you your chain when you
come to thick Boy Studio but thank you
for being part of this thank you for
believing in me thank you for being
making something special being funny
being talented being so entertaining
that makes this network run thank you to
everybody thanks to the staff enjoy your
holidays enjoy your Christmas your
Hanukkah
your New Year's
um and uh I will see you on the other
side this is the last show of 2022 for
the thick Boy network and uh there's no
other way I'd like to go out so enjoy
the content I will see you on the other
side I will see you next year 2023
coming in hot we have more in the works
telling you guys we're just getting
started so thank you guys so much I love
you congrats all the winners until next
time be safe have a happy holiday Merry
Christmas Happy New Year I'll see you in
2023. I'm out if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding